[Musique]
ici mieux vaut ne pas s'amuser à compter
les moutons
mais les collines les vallées sont
façonnés par ces tondeuses 100 % nature
pour eux on a arraché des arbres plantés
des barrières et des boisés les deux
tiers du territoire
la nouvelle zélande compte en fait dix
fois plus de moutons que d'habitants au
total ils sont 40 millions
[Musique]
pour s'occuper d'eux et de leur
toilettage un métier particulier a même
été créé
les tondeurs de moutons il parcourt le
pays de ferme en ferme
sebastian est un débutant dans la
profession c'est seulement son troisième
jour mais déjà pour son corps c'est une
épreuve
il vaut mieux s'étirer avant de
commencer c'est bon pour s'échauffer le
dos mais aussi les jambes
j'ai débuté il y à peu je me suis blessé
dès le premier jour alors aujourd'hui je
vais pas forcer
les bêtes peuvent peser jusqu'à 160 kg
alors mieux vaut se préparer
car huit heures de travail attend de ces
professionnels du rasoir un effort que
travis prend lui avec philosophie il
faut dire que c'est le plus ancien de la
bande
il y en a un bon millier à tondre
ça veut dire que chacun de nous va
devoir en faire 250
ça va aller c'est faisable
en moins d'une minute l'animal est
débarrassé de sa toison sans souffrance
[Musique]
pas question de perdre une seconde la
paye dépend du nombre de moutons du
on peut se faire beaucoup d'argent avec
la tente il faut être rapide tout au
long de la journée et ça demande
beaucoup d'entraînement
[Musique]
un mouton peut donner jusqu'à 5 kg de
laine
la nouvelle zélande fournit le quart de
la production mondiale
[Musique]
j'ai fini et je suis toujours en vie
c'est une bonne journée j'ai dû entendre
c 200 moutons rasé vont lui rapporter
250 euros un score de débutants comparé
à trévise le plus expérimenté
j'ai fait 295 moutons
en serveur 15
c'est plutôt une bonne journée
le mouton est donc un peu l'or blanc de
la nouvelle zélande non seulement ils
donnent du travail mais surtout il peut
rapporter gros
le lendemain ces saisonniers de la tonte
s'attaqueront à mille autres bêtes dans
une autre exploitation dans la région de
thé cuite hi
tekk 8i sur l'île du nord c'est un peu
l'eldorado pour le tondeur dès l'entrée
de la ville le ton est donné
chaque semaine on marche et 2000 bêtes
s'échange dans quelques heures
ces enchères des vides fagen les connaît
bien tout le monde dit s'il admire des
vides c'est un géant de la tonte il a
vraiment heureux pour moi
celui qui tombe presque plus vite que
son ombre est un exemple pour tous
des vides a fait fortune grâce aux
moutons
tondre m'a permis d'acheter ma ferme
c'est certain c'est pour ça que je me
suis mis à le faire pour l'argent on
peut gagner beaucoup il faut que tu
t'entraînes dur et que tu acceptes de te
déplacer dans pas mal d'endroits
encore il savoir comment bien utiliser
cet argent à la fin tu as bossé dur
toute ta vie mais tu est sur d'avoir
quelque chose à toi
[Musique]
et voici le fruit d'années de tonte un
ranch et une centaine d'hectares
mais tondre ce n'est pas seulement un
métier
c'est aussi en sports
lors de ma dernière compétition ils
m'ont offert ce souvenir avec des photos
qui résume bien mon palmarès
celui là c'est le trophée des golden
shares j'ai remporté seize fois ce qui
est plutôt pas mal
les golden chez eux ce sont des
championnats nationaux un évènement
organisé chaque année des vides en est
la légende
il a derrière lui trente ans de
compétition et des milliers de
supporters mais à 55 ans il vient de
décider de raccrocher à la quête sujet
vraiment ça dans le sang j'ai adoré la
compétition j'avais soif de victoire et
en plus j'ai pu représenter mon pays à
l'étranger avec l'équipe de nouvelle
zélande pratiquer ce sport chaque
week-end ça m'a aidé à tondre bien mieux
mais
qu elle
david a déjà son successeur
p
ouais
il vite à une centaine de km au sud
[Musique]
dt
kevin match a quitté son écosse natale
il ya quinze ans et il a débarqué ici
un peu comme ces boule de laine arrivait
avec les colons britanniques
il y a deux siècles
moi j'ai grandi avec les moutons
chez mon grand-père était éleveur est
aussi un tondeur
en fait toute ma vie se résume aux
moutons
c'est ma passion et parfois je me dis
qu'il vaut mieux bosser avec ses bêtes
chez plutôt qu'avec certaines personnes
chez les matches a pas être un héros
surtout depuis qu'il a arraché la plus
prestigieuse des récompenses
celle que david sagan avait remporté
seize fois
[Musique]
c'est ça le graal quand on fait de la
compétition de haut niveau c'est quelque
chose de fort de voir son nom gravé là
dessus moi ça m'a fait quelque chose
je suis très fier
j'espère que nos enfants vont une
passion aussi forte que leur papa
tu veux le temps dieu
[Musique]
dans quelques jours kelvin remettra son
trophée en jeu
pour être le meilleur il doit
s'entraîner dur on ne tond que deux fois
par an
alors pour ses quatre enfants l'occasion
est trop belle de manquer l'école
[Musique]
c'est de la relève pourvu qu'ils
n'abandonnent pas
en compétition il n'aura que quelques
secondes pour tondre un mouton alors
kévin à une technique bien à lui
d'abord vous voyez je commence par le
ventre je fais trois ou quatre bandes
comme ça sur le ventre
[Musique]
et puis ensuite j'enlève la laine des
pâtes
[Musique]
thor
en fait il faut bien tenir le mouton
pour pouvoir le bouger facilement
ça stresse moins l'animal
et plus tu es doux avec le mouton plus
c'est facile de le tondre
s'il n'est pas bien il va te rendre le
travail bien plus difficile
c'est un gros cela tu veux tendre dans
la vase ithaca le faire toi
c'est le grand jour pour gueye vinh
la compétition va se dérouler ici à web
ou courau dans l'est de l'île
on y célèbre l'esprit des pionniers et
l'univers de la ferme si particulier à
la nouvelle zélande
la vedette c'est le mouton évidemment
plus de 600 ont été acheminés pour
l'occasion ils vont passer entre les
mains des meilleurs fondeurs du pays
[Musique]
tu vois là je poli la lame pour éviter
de blesser l'animal
plus la lame est douce plus la laine
glisse entre l'étang du rasoir et donc
tu peut tondre plus vite
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue à la
finale avec l'élite des tondeurs
et voici le dernier vainqueur des golden
shares est le champion du monde en titre
kevin match
[Musique]
les chronos sont prêts messieurs à vos
marques
c'est parti
ce sont tous des all blacks du rasoir
dans la mêlée kevin
au même titre que le rugby la tonte à
tout d'un sport de haut niveau
avec ses arbitres qui scrutent la
moindre blessure
son public de mordus et ses journalistes
pour couvrir l'événement
je suis un des seuls journalistes au
monde spécialisée dans l'atome de
moutons on doit être quatre ou cinq
gueye vinh à 10 minutes pour convaincre
pour notre ami écossais notre game in il
se donne du mal
on va finir par mettre le kilt s'il
continue à ce rythme
première étape chaque concurrent doit
t'on drv un mouton
en compétition la tonte parfaite s'est
détaché le manteau laineux d'un bloc
pour le gagnant à la clé un prix de 600
euros
s'il garde ce rythme il finira premier
mais il est aussi notée sur la qualité
de la tonte donc il peut être le plus
rapide mais s'il fait des erreurs ça lui
coûtera la victoire on sera fixé dès que
les juges auront livré leur verdict
la dextérité du champion en titre fait
merveille et il est le plus rapide à
venir au bout de ses 28 ans
bolloré
non
hautmont
mais c'est en fait lors de la seconde
étape que tout va se jouer
en coulisses là où le jury va évaluer la
qualité de la tente
[Musique]
les juges sont en train de regarder si
j'ai fait des erreurs si le mouton est
complètement tondu ou pas et s'il a des
blessures
et là bas ils inscrivent les scores ça
va directement dans un ordinateur et ce
score ajouter autant va donner le nombre
de points total
[Musique]
après discussion avec les juges kevin
n'est pas vraiment confiant
mais je crois que j'étais un peu
brusques quand même
je fasse mieux la prochaine fois
mais tu as fait meilleur temps
oui et c'est ce que le public retient
m
kevin a bien gagné la bataille du
chronomètre mais le champion aujourd'hui
c'est david bohic
la rapidité n'aura donc pas suffi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il termine bon troisième est bon perdant
c'est comme n'importe quel sport en fait
tu deviens vite accro
chaque week-end tu veux te surpasser
pour être le meilleur
ce résultat là il est vraiment dur à
encaisser
mais bon je ne me vois pas arrêter
dans leurs rêves les plus fous ces
champions de la tonte espère qu'un jour
leur sport deviendra discipline
olympique
[Musique]